Only one of these can be
solved using map, and
that's adding one to each
element in the input array.
Why can we do that?
Each individual element in this input
array, is processed in parallel.
We can't sort an input array using
map because the output at any
position is dependent
on all the input data.
Similarly, to sum up all the elements in
an input array, requires that we look at
all of the separate elements
to compute a single output.
The individual elements
are not parallel.
Finally to compute the average
of an input array,
also requires this all the one
style of communication.
We don't have in parallel things
that happen independently
without any communication.
Now, all these other operations are
very, very interesting in GPU computing,
and we will absolutely be covering
them in the next few units.